لذلك نحن هنا في حي سكني
أه قريب جدًا من أحدكم
في مطار جوليانا بمطار كييف
ويمكنك أن ترى ورائي أنا فقط
سأخرج من الطريق حتى يتمكن
مصورتي scotty mcwinny من إظهار الضرر لك هنا
لقد تم تنفيذ ذلك ، لقد
أصابت قذيفة نوعًا ما هذا
المبنى السكني في حوالي الساعة 8 15
صباحًا ، نسمع أنه لا يزال بإمكانك
رؤية الدخان يتصاعد منه ، وكان هناك حريق كبير
لا يزال يدخن ، وهناك
عمال إسعاف في الموقع وماذا كانوا
نحاول الآن أخذ بعض
السقالات هناك لمحاولة
منع انهيار الطابقين 22 و 23
ولكن
بأعجوبة
لم يُقتل أحد في هذه
الضربة التي نسمعها من
السلطات الأوكرانية أن ستة أشخاص أصيبوا بجروح
بصراحة من الصعب تخيل  كيف
نجا أي شخص ولكن ستة أشخاص
أصيبوا بجروح إنهم يتلقون العلاج أه في
مستشفيات مختلفة وهناك
القليل مما قاله إنها تتحدث عن
كيفية حدوث ذلك وتقول السلطات الأوكرانية
ذلك  كان هذا من عمل
صاروخ روسي والروس
يقولون إنهم يعتقدون معذرةً ، آسف
لأن الرياح شديدة هنا وهناك الكثير
من الحطام المتطاير حول الروس
يقولون إنهم يعتقدون
أن هذا كان في الواقع
نظام دفاع صاروخي أوكراني ذهب بطريقة ما
انحرفت وانتهى الأمر بضرب هذا
المبنى السكني الآن بغض النظر عن المسؤول ،
ومع ذلك حدث هذا ، فإن الواقع هو أن
هذا هو الشيء الذي يحدث
عندما يكون لديك حرب تدور في
مدينة كبرى مثل كييف ، هذه
مدينة يبلغ عدد سكانها ما يقرب من
2.9 مليون شخص  ونحن في
منطقة مركزية جميلة هنا ، هذا ليس
نوعًا مما
تعرفه في الضواحي البعيدة للمدينة ،
يمكنك فقط أن تتخيل مدى
رعب الأشخاص الذين كانوا نائمين أو
استيقظوا لتناول الإفطار مع
عائلاتهم في  صباح يوم السبت
خائفون بالفعل من الموقف
ليجدوا المبنى قد
أصيب
في هذا الهجوم